tom andy has you know let's say a bit of
experience uh working with the
characters that are essentially two
characters in the same body did that was
that something that factored a lot into
uh the decision to ask him to come and
do this huge yeah
huge because we've done um the first one
and uh
and it was a great experience
in many ways uh and and this and as soon
as we we've got it over the line and we
knit on the second one um
the requests started to go out to the
studio of of
optionality and opportunities or what we
could do with it learning from the
lessons that we had from the feedback of
the first and so as largely
my department is is performance-based uh
and story based uh
the two things to have to line up let's
make a really great story i you know
what's the story we can tell and let's
get some really great storytellers in
and and who else
you know is the hybrid of both the
ability to direct you know epic work you
know um
but at the same time
has
you know arguably
and i've said it before and it sounds
chad but it's true you're arguably one
of the greatest character actors of of
certain of my generation
i mean who
who does this literally as his bread and
butter so also i have a i have a short
hand with
you know i can talk to and say hey look
um
i've doing okay with this bit but how do
i progress that bill how do we you know
move this around not just necessarily
with uh
animation or cgi or motion capture but
as an actor you know
it's a it's a really particular language
that you speak and so when you speak
with somebody who has the elasticity and
ability and range and is not intimidated
by the concept and can see what
someone's reaching for
it's a much quicker shorthand you know
so yes move faster so it's a super
no-brainer but that isn't that is very
generous of you but i mean i have to i
have to come back i have to come back at
that by saying by saying tom tom
so understands and
you know the nature of it the very fiber
of how to do this anyway so i was just
lucky enough to to watch what was going
on basically he
he the way that he crafted this
character was on a daily basis a pure an
exercise in great great acting and
reacting um and i know so quite
seriously and and the ability to to to
to form that relationship between the
two characters in his head and then when
it manifests was was sublime you know it
really was truly sublime so
i you know it was
i was the lucky one there we had fun we
did we knew it was going to be fun
because you were both bonkers like that
i guess
for the experience you know an
investigation yeah
well it's what's fun about this but i
think bonkers is a great word because
what's really fun about these movies is
just the idea that you can go
do these bonkers things and venom is one
of the most popular comics characters in
the world and the opportunity to bring
carnage to the screen for the very first
time and andy to be at the helm of that
that must have been very exciting for
you
it really well i mean
you know to have to have that tom
at the center of it all and then to
bring in woody and and as cletus and
that energy and his own fantastic
you know sort of off-center off-kilter
you know as even just as cletus and on
top of that to to to have his input into
creating all of our inputs but because
it was a very collaborative exercise but
to creating this thing that was a really
in that it was a really uh dangerous
witty uh sophisticated but twisted um
nemesis that that you just can't kind of
grab literally because he's sort of he
just the way that he moves physically is
so
um slippery and and left field and that
that i mean that and that came out of
the comics we did a lot of studies into
how carnage moves how to how to make
making different and everybody wants to
see kanye you know
carnage is the you know that's what they
you know
obviously the spider-man thing is the
spider-man thing but within the world of
symbiotes carnage is the reveal you know
we had such pressure and on and sheena
and the team there and
and
you know with andy to deliver
a nemesis like you say which which
people who don't know will enjoy if you
don't know the the
venom comics and all we've got whoa
and those who do know
recognize us see the manifestation of of
a lot of their
their you know their passion for the
character in it and i think woody
delivers on a level which is
well you know he he's deliciously wicked
yeah and a brilliant actor yeah perfect
i mean to that with him he's
always such a
amazing joy isn't it easy yeah yeah he's
a brilliant team player as well he's
fantastic he's
awesome
as expected now i mean carnage is uh an
incredible incredible character for this
movie but how do you go bigger for venom
three tom who do you bring in for the
next one um i think
i think you're gonna always look at
like any any with these things they come
in threes at the moment and if they
progress further then it's normally the
initial blocking of of the
infrastructure of a set of franchise
movies will be one two and three and
done
so
when venom one was presented it was
presented if it was successful with the
two and if that was successful the three
so one has to look at the whole
overarching uh option and first you
establish a character if people like it
then you take them on a journey
obviously carnage is you know
it it's
he's a high priest in that aspect of
in the uh and in the arcana of the
of the characters it's like wow you got
to go bigger you know or you go lateral
and build the world you continue to
unpack there's a there's a venom verse
you know that you know there's a there's
a spider verse there's multiverses
there's all kinds of uh
canon and lore and mythology to explore
both laterally and forward in time and
and and i think with the right people
and the right planning and
and feedback from the audience and
understanding it
it's it's about making the right choices
at the right time
even with foresight of understanding
where things may go already or they wish
to go
it's a it's a combination of all of
those in the alchemy of what it will be